може я тихо ден переговорів і думав вони
справа трубку дорожні карти для тили
німецьких ось так і результат зустрічі у
нормандському форматі у берліні Дева та
прориву про переговори ніхто четвер і
навчи кулів на цівку завалу та експерти
у team впав на важливий і не мати кого у
ряду випробувань спектра this росію-то
краї на масці дно та Європи місто ірлар
результатом це задоволений і козаки
результат часто suite україни archos
правді все-таки буде тіла, але то в нас е
новий шанс чекати на нього було так
чудово шкіряних нових будинків вона стоїть про
при полоні не вигнута віджимання тисячі через
скільки днів бої схибив і знову сів
будинків на місці про розвідали сил можна
чи буде нова кістки ще убік
доповіді tissues і для тіні
тримайте через конфлікт однак експерти
називають прогресом сам факт зустрічі
на найвищому рівні
он вона думка про завдання було потрібно по
роду символ димарі путіну через ніч
співаєш і не видно син росії з Європи
це США і йому поверни супроводі
навик санте ще до кремля за dieu сирії
в тому до того ще росія ви кано взяти
вона сама мавпочкою експерт залишатиме
скептично часто рубриці кис
тактичний худим а б показати і ще
Росія тут але готова до компромісу в
конструктивних до руки та діалогу
all in hd світло в козу і на 1000 ціна
мене і російський пінхед думаю всього
разу путін знову хочемо на дислокацій
тактовний сигнал
alike шум та подивимося уми null та
essence поставить все скептично до того
що означає йому честь суді ви цим
альтернатива нормандському у форматі німа
сцен паху джеймса та політикою експерти
сайт шийці найменшим ольгу вириті на
адже призначені результати по
патчу м'яз вилізти їй дорожню карту
більше 70 че будда прогрес у всіх
будинкового ностях думаю якщо патчі до тієї
дати їм шанс проговоримо aetr його ти від
ж політичні проблеми виникнуть з
картою росія україна та європа на зло
батіг з карти свиту вища через ти ще
рішення називають мертвим
став дтп чини вперше прогресу
переговорах визнана яга українська
бік так і вас подарунку самі так він
слайд немічений ангела меркель створити
фундамент для чого прогресу might
appear міністра закордонних справ до
кінця листопада он і по ви не
затвердіти та основу проекту дорожні
карти